Você sabia que tomar sol pode proteger o
seu cérebro da demência? Pesquisadores
americanos analisaram o cérebro de quase
300 idosos e fizeram uma descoberta
impressionante. Quem tinha níveis mais
altos de vitamina D no cérebro teve até
33% menos chance de desenvolver demência
ou problemas de memória. Não é só sobre
tomar suplemento, não. O sol faz muito
mais que isso. Quando você se expõe ao
sol, seu cérebro produz mais serotonina
que aquele neurotransmissor que melhora
o humor e regula o sono. Por isso que a
gente se sente tão bem num dia
ensolarado. E veja bem, não precisa
torrar no sol. 15 minutinhos por dia já
fazem uma diferença enorme. O problema é
que hoje em dia a gente vive trancado,
trabalha em escritório, fica em ar
condicionado, por isso tanta gente
precisa suplementar a vitamina D, mas
mesmo tomando suplemento, continua
importante pegar sol. Ele mexe com seus
hormônios, com seus neurotransmissores,
tem benefícios que vão muito além da
vitamina D. E claro, acompanhe os seus
níveis de vitamina D nos exames e seu
cérebro agradece.